if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
or bph your prostate gland is enlarged
the prostate is a walnut-sized gland in
men
just beneath your bladder your prostate
gland surrounds your urethra the tube
through which urine and semen exit your
body
your seminal vesicles and prostate make
fluid that combines with sperm cells to
create semen
during normal urination urine flows from
your bladder through the part of your
urethra inside your prostate then
through the rest of your urethra to
leave your body
for unknown reasons your prostate gland
may enlarge as you get older
if you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
your prostate may grow large enough to
narrow or block the part of your urethra
that runs through it as a result your
enlarged prostate may slow or block the
urine flow out of your body when you
urinate